[Musique]
il s'appelle alma stella kevin mélanie
boulay a pour eux l'école est synonyme
d'échec ou de souffrance leur chance
aujourd'hui est d'avoir trouvé une
structure pour apprendre qu'ils ont un
avenir et qu'un autre chemin est
possible
le château des veaux en eure-et-loir le
plus gros établissements scolaires des
apprentis d'auteuil avec 800 élèves
depuis 70 ans
on y accueille les jeunes en difficulté
avec plusieurs dispositifs anti
décrochage alma est arrivé ici en
février dernier après avoir été
déscolarisés en banlieue parisienne
puisque je suis pas allé à l'école
pendant un an le temps de reprendre les
cours je pense que ça m'a un peu stressé
parce que j'avais déjà des difficultés
auparavant et de les remettre sur le
tabac ça m'a un peu stressé
ils nous aident dans tous que ça soit
extérieur au lycée et dans l'ensemble du
lycée pour les matières professionnelles
et générales et du coup en fait on n'a
pas de stress quand même à l'école dès
que tu es dès que je comprends rien je
le dis et du coup ça fonctionne
alors que j'ai fait un collège normal et
c'est hyper mal passé parce que les
profs ils n'étaient pas adaptés à mes
problèmes et donc les fractions j'ai
tout réussi mais par exemple dans lé là
aussi mais c'est en exercice comme ça tu
l'as fait tout seul message des faits
tout c'est un lieu d'écouté mais on ne
vient pas là juste pour faire un cours
quoi et je pense que pour certains
beaucoup de jeunes il redécouvre le
monde de l'école avec voilà avec
d'autres relations avec les enseignants
les formateurs bonjour c'est bien sa
journée d'intégration et découverte du
métier
le post est prêt au château des veaux
chaque jeune déscolarisé peut tester un
ou plusieurs métiers avant de faire son
choix
moi ce que je vis aujourd'hui c'est que
tu
me détaille convenablement qu'une phase
une brunoise correcte et que tube est
mince un oignon on va déjà acquérir le
bon geste
c'est un bon apprentissage parce que
c'est à ce moment là où eux n'ont jamais
eu cette rigueur on ne leur a jamais
fait comprendre qu'il fallait une
rigueur pour avancer voilà il arrive une
cuisine qui est quand même un peu
militarisé avec un secteur où on dit
voilà il faut qu'il fasse ceci fasse
cela qu'il fasse comme si qu'ils fassent
comme ça mais c'est étape par étape
kevin lui aussi n'allait plus à l'école
victime de harcèlement au collège il a
suivi des cours à distance pendant deux
ans avant d'arriver au château des veaux
j'ai pu vraiment me rapprocher des
autres pouvoir mieux dialoguer
disputée et autres ça m'a vraiment fait
permis d'être un peu plus sociable vu
que je m'étais totalement renfermé sur
moi-même pendant deux ans la beauté de
ce métier c'est un jeune on le prend
dans son entité dont ce qu'il est avec
son parcours mais pas dans le jugement
la difficulté on leva lui et c'est nous
le travail de l'éducateur mais aussi des
professeurs ici sont pas qu'un
professeur et son bep la gorgue et ils
sont aussi éducateur c'est d'amener le
jeune dans un projet qu'il siens et de
200 violence dans la compréhension mais
c'est de l'amener à ça en quelques mois
alma a réussi à refaire son retard cette
année elle intègre un bac pro de vente
en jardinerie une formation qui concilie
ses deux passions
je suis à l'aise à l'oral et à
m'exprimer et que j'ai pas peur bas je
sais que je pourrais aller loin dans
dans le match et que je veux faire
après une idée pressé je sais pas du
tout débat de normalement je voulais
faire maraîchers et ensuite je pense que
je vais faire un chef d'entreprise
aujourd'hui une réponse
[Musique]
l'école de la deuxième chance à blois
est une structure dédiée aux jeunes sans
qualification ici il faut de la
motivation pour être acceptée alternez
cours de remise à niveau et stages en
entreprise
un défi pour ces jeunes meurtri par la
vie est souvent broyés par le système
scolaire pour stella
le salut est d'abord venu de sa famille
d'accueil
j'ai refusé d'apprendre à lire et écrire
jusqu'à l'âge de 13 ans et puis un jour
à la dila je peux pas te je peux pas
continuer at laisser les et enfoncé quoi
scolairement ahmadi on prend un livre et
on commence à apprendre à lire
ça a été étape par étape donc un mot sur
1 2 une phrase sur 2 puis de fil en
aiguille pas j'ai fini par apprendre à
lire comme ça mon premier livre à est
harry potter mélanie a été victime de
harcèlement
en troisième j'ai tenté de ce site et
les bleus clermont se quitter dans la
classe comme on en avait marre
l'ordinaire tout ce que vous me dites
vous fait du mal je me fais du mal moi
même et déjà on sait
chaque semaine il y a démâté du français
en groupe et sous forme d'exercices
pratiques avec une autre pédagogie
l'idée c'est dire bah si ça tu te
laisses est ravie forcément un moment
donné où ça ça va être utile pour telle
et telle chose dans sa vie quotidienne
donc voilà c'est vraiment se détacher du
scolaire on est pour nous c'est des
stagiaires de la formation
professionnelle le contexte de l'école
il est écarté et les lois ni on part de
la situation de maintenant pour aller
vers vers demain tu lèves toi tu prends
sur toi mais s'il n'a plus droit aux
apprenants le centre pour la cl etienne
[Musique]
on se retient de faire les choses de
peur en voiture c'est vrai que c'est m
mais le fait d'avoir peur des fois ça
nous bloque sur pas mal de choses et le
fait aussi de d'écouter les gens aussi
voit l'affluence des gens jouer et la
famille aussi surtout quand quand est-ce
que traumatise compter petit et elle te
compare avec les gens à huy lui il a eu
17 watts a eu 10 en plus des cours les
jeunes participent à des ateliers où la
parole se libère
je suis pas mal de difficultés sur mes
crises angoisse donc je ne peux pas
voilà quand il ya une réunion de groupe
je ne peux pas je peux pas vraiment
parler ce que j'ai paniqué que je suis
pas à l'aise
- mes difficultés c'est le fait de nous
enfermer par exemple et d'avoir très peu
de contacts avec des gens que je
connaissais pas du coup ça m'a donné
beaucoup de difficultés ça ça m'a fait
développé une peur pour l'inconnu par
exemple qui m'a souvent empêché de me
lancer dans quelque chose
pas à cause de soi j'ai vu des
transformations extraordinaire des gens
qui au début avait vraiment du mal à et
quand je dis du mal c'était vraiment une
grosse difficulté à parler au sein du
groupe
déjà ça se voyait très bien au début
parce qu il se mette à l'écart du groupe
et puis à la fin enfin rayonner sourit
enfin sincèrement oui j'ai en mémoire
plusieurs plusieurs personnes qui bat je
redis roi qui se sont peut-être révélé à
elle même j'ai envie en fait de trouver
du travail m'en sortir pour voir montre
à mon fils que je suis capable de
beaucoup de choses en fait je fais tout
ça pour moi même mais aussi pour montrer
à mon enfant que ben même si on a des
échecs des déceptions des coups de mou
et sans faut toujours savoir se relever
tant réussi à vraiment pas confiance en
moi là je commence à avoir plus
confiance en moi qu'au début on n'a pas
témoigné comme ça avant de passer ici
[Musique]
pour résumer ma carrière sportive
à 12 ans j'ai découvert mon sport à 14
ans j'entre en équipe de france
à 16 ans j'ai été renvoyé de mon lycée
surmonter l'échec scolaire
c'est le credo de muriel hermine
l'ancienne championne de natation
artistique a créé l'académie des
passions pendant trois jours en
immersion des jeunes en galère découvre
que la réussite à l'école est basé sur
une seule forme d'intelligence
les spécialistes en dénombre e8 toutes
différentes et toutes reliées à des
compétences
le titre love surprise c'est que dans
l'intérêt personnel moi qui suis
beaucoup avec les hôtes et qui partagent
énormément
eh ben j'ai moins de deux
caractéristiques que je pensais à peine
un mois c'est mon quatrième et il a
compensé
comme on ne peut pas changer le monde
extérieur qu'on peut changer que notre
monde
il faut commencer par travailler sur soi
et travailler sur soi encore avec des
outils qui intéresse les jeunes le sport
la culture les nouvelles technologies le
coaching permettent de
d'aller les chercher non plus dans dans
le mental dans cette espèce d'intellect
que le français aime tant développés
mais aller chercher dans l'intimité
derniers ont d'ailleurs paraît qu'on y
voir rc dans votre voiture est 100
naturel les contenterait d'une avenue
tout tracé paraît dangereux sont les
ruelles institutions quitte à prendre
des départs à l'académie des passions le
stage en immersion inclut des activités
sportives pour faire émerger
l'intelligence émotionnelle entre
accrobranche et parcours de survie le
jeune bénéficie d'un coaching individuel
comme léa qui a dû arrêter le sport
études à cause d'une blessure j'avais
beaucoup de rêves beaucoup de choses
vous est vrai que j'ai décroché
et c'est pas facile de se relever seul
donc je suis déçue de moi même un peu
parce que je pense que j'aurais pu être
capable de faire mieux
j'ai besoin en fait d'avoir un moment
donné quelqu'un qui de soutien quoi
quelqu'un qui m'aide et qui qui montrent
que c'est possible que je peux avoir
confiance en moi et que rien à perdre
quoi lorsque vous allez toucher
l'émotion vous touchez l'intelligence
émotionnelle comme son nom l'indiqué qui
fait que c'est des jeunes qui
considèrent tellement qu'ils sont pas
bons à l'école qu'ils sont intelligents
et cetera que il
il se frustre hills empêche plein de
choses non c'est la pta jambes
non maintenant aller vite c'est dur
aujourd'hui vit de petits pains
et puis avant à travers l'accord 4
devant toi je vais me réveiller avec la
fierté c'est trop donc je serai fier
savoir s'est transformée et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui des programmes que ceux
de l'académie les patients viennent
compléter compléter quelque chose que
l'éducation nationale n'a pas pris
encore en trouver pour y prendre en
compte avec une nouvelle approche s'il
le décide c'est justement cet aspect
global de la personne le physique
l'émotionnel et nos montagnes
six cent vingt mille jeunes de 18 à 24
ans se trouve aujourd'hui sans diplôme
et sans travail un chiffre qui baisse
grâce à ceux qui croient en des
pédagogies différentes
une façon de mettre le jeune au centre
de l'enseignement pour ne pas le laisser
à la porte de la société
[Musique]